Oh
well of course it's not dead but what
has happened is that tolerance which we
on the whole used to regard as a
positive term have more and more has
become a very negative one and that
those who are afraid that the West or
Europe in particular is going to be
Islamized that Europe is going to end up
as eurabia that will be swamped by
intolerant Muslims and so on tend to see
tolerance as at best indifference at
worst sort of cowardly appeasement and
collaboration with Islamic Islam of
fascism I think that's very regrettable
because tolerance in the sense of being
able to live with people whose opinions
or values you may not share as long as
everybody bides by the law and doesn't
start you know slitting each other's
throats I think it's necessary and you
can't demand and the United States is a
good example of this that you the entire
population shares exactly the same
cultural values it's it's impossible nor
should one demand it I mean the
diversity is part of the societies we
live in
well multiculturalism as if it's simply
a description of a society which
consists of various different cultures
and languages is one thing we live in
such societies multiculturalism as an
ideology that somehow supposes that or
promotes the idea that people should
stick to their own culture and not
integrate or assimilate and I think is
wrong but I think as an ideology it's
it's it's certainly on the way out I
don't think that that many people
believe in that anymore I think that
when you think of it in that dogmatic
way it harms minorities because they're
not encouraged to learn the skills or
the languages that would allow them to
take part in the societies and the
economies in the way that would be
beneficial to them
well India is rather a good example of a
place which has institutionalized
multiculturalism in the sense that it
includes a population of very different
cultures and and even ethnicities and I
don't just mean Muslims and Hindus there
are a huge number of different languages
in India and so on and somehow it works
even though there are instances of
violence and tensions and it's a
democracy that's hugely problematic but
it works they found a way of dealing
with it that actually probably the West
in its more hysterical moments could
learn something from Indonesia likewise
was only a nation-state because of
because of the Dutch colonial history
made at that it's a highly diverse and
it's only just become a democracy and
showing many tensions but I think again
one probably we should be paying more
attention to Indonesia because it's the
country with the largest Muslim
population in the world and when people
say Islam is incompatible with democracy
they should take another look at
Indonesia
well the violence that comes from
radical Islamists for example is
sometimes blamed on a clash of
civilizations that somehow different
traditions one a non-western one one a
European one are sort of violently
clashing I think that's a mistake it's
it's a mistaken analysis because the
people who drop bombs in the London
Underground for example are not guest
workers from little villages in Anatolia
or the Rif mountains of Morocco they're
people born in Europe and raised in
Europe who often grew up not knowing
much about religion and I think they
indeed are often in a kind of no man's
land which is very often true of
second-generation immigrants where they
are alienated from the culture of their
parents or grandparents and feel
rejected for one reason or another by
the country in which they grew up and of
course they're vulnerable particularly
vulnerable to violent causes all young
people are vulnerable to them but
they're perhaps especially vulnerable